[Music]
how you feeling about this season it's
good it's really good I'm and I enjoyed
myself I had a good time I feel like we
are due for a really good season for you
like a happy season you think I think
maybe a Redemption season I don't know
go figure I'll tell you how it's
different I come in by myself I'm alone
I have no one and you know what I have
to put my big girl pants on and flippin
deal that Lisa Rinna back in action in
Beverly Hills
the girls who started modeling I'm like
a teenage wrangling momager right now
the season you have your momager cap on
a lot I think I have it on a lot I mean
I have mad respect for Kris Jenner let
me just say that I really do
I've always liked Kris Jenner I know how
mad I now have mad respect for her
because she does it times six or more
I'm doing it for two and it is a
full-time job
okay way more wait harder than my own
job but I'm happily doing it I love it
so much I wouldn't want it any other way
it is thrilling did you reach out to
Kris or any of your other friends who
are in kind of the same spot for advice
I didn't I do
I mean Cindy Crawford's a friend of mine
so that's pretty handy I mean you know
she's kind of an expert I'd say um
anyway they're very cool so I of course
talked to Cindy a lot about it and
auntie kris so it's helpful I'm just
thinking back a year ago and they were
just getting started it's no joke now
it's like real like it's a real deal you
know I know 18 months ago 15 months ago
they were working at the deli hello
life has changed but everybody's good
they're good girls they have their heads
on straight you know I pray you always
pray but things are going well one day
at a time
how does Harry Hamlin feel about all the
attention on those two Harry Hamlin is
so excited
by it it's the cutest thing ever like he
wants to know like fill me and he's not
you know he's not being a data jerk but
he wants to know daily what's going on
what's the news like he walked in
tonight he said okay what's the news he
wants to know who's up for what who got
what it's really cute so he definitely
wants to be involved